Bender Rodriguez has a defender on him, unleashes
with his right foot!
Gooooooooaaaaaaallllll Bot-celona!
Hello everyone, Julian here for DNews.
Artificial Intelligence is the holy grail
of computing and robotics.
A machine that can intelligently analyze and
manipulate its environment to achieve a goal
is no small feat, and at first it was believed
that the ultimate challenge for AI was winning
a game of chess.
It makes sense at a glance: chess masters
are brilliant strategists who carefully analyze
and react to their opponents in order to win.
If a computer can beat one of them, then surely
we’ve cracked this nut, right?
Well a computer has beaten a chess master.
18 years ago.
So why hasn’t Skynet taken over?
Because chess is not the perfect problem for
AI that we once thought it was.
Chess is actually relatively easy for a computer.
Chess is only against one opponent, and everything
happens sequentially.
A computer knows that when it makes a move,
exactly what it intended to happen will happen.
And even though there are millions and millions
of possible moves, the slow pace of the game
means the computer can calculate exactly all
of them and cherry pick the best one.
Basically winning chess for a computer is
less intelligence and more brute force calculations.
But in 1997, the same year Deep Blue defeated
chess champion Gary Kasparov, another tournament
was started, and it involved a game much harder
for robots.
I’m talking of course, about soccer.
Yes, soccer.
The tournament is called the “Robot Soccer
World Cup,” so soccer is the correct term.
Plus soccer is old British slang for “Association
Football,” so I don’t want to see a bunch
of comments about how it’s called football.
Anyway, soccer poses problems for AI that
chess never could.
Instead of reacting to one other player, there
are entire teams.
It’s not turn based, but constant and dynamic.
The robot cannot predict exactly where the
ball will go when it kicks it; it could take
a strange bounce or another robot could intercept
it.
That means the robots have to react to unexpected
events, and they have to do so quickly, none
of this faffing about while it decides what
to do.
Plus robot soccer is tractable; it can easily
be recreated over and over anywhere in the
world.
It’s not as challenging as creating a robot
that’s almost human, and it’s not too
expensive.
It also helps that soccer is the most popular
sport in the world, so robot soccer would
probably gain some attention.
And indeed it has.
When the first RoboCup was held in Nagoya,
Japan, there were 38 teams from 11 countries.
Last year there were 358 teams from 45 countries.
The number of categories has grown immensely
too.
Originally RoboCup had only 3 leagues; small
robots that used an overhead camera, medium
robots with their own sensors, and AI playing
soccer solely in a simulation.
Then in 1999 RoboCup introduced the first
league with legged robots.
The robots they used?
Specially programmed Sony AIBO dogs.
Yes those little plastic dogs your aunt got
you for christmas because she had no idea
what to get you actually served a purpose
advancing science.
Now the legged divisions are humanoid, and
can either be a standard platform or entirely
custom built.
They’ve also branched away from soccer,
and have competitions for search and rescue
robots and robot dancers.
Most importantly though, all the robots are
autonomous and independent.
The eventual goal is to have a robot soccer
squad capable of beating the human world cup
champions by the year 2050.
Watch out Messi, Robo-naldo is coming for
you.
Competition is one of the best ways to drive
innovation, and when brilliant dedicated people
come together, they can achieve amazing things.
In the same way the United States Air Force
is powered by Airmen and fueled by innovation,
and we’d like to thank them for sponsoring
this episode.